good morning Hank it's Tuesday today's
video is like the human sternum it comes
to you in three parts part one the
manubrium so the 10th annual project for
awesome nerdfighteria San Yule charity
event begins at noon Eastern Time on
Friday that's when you should upload
your project for awesome videos and
submit them to projectforawesome.com but
the indiegogo fundraiser will go live at
midnight tonight and you can get lots of
great perks for donating including a
project for awesome tote bag pee for a
socks an exclusive episode of dear Hank
and John and an audio recording of me
reading about 15 pages from a thing I'm
working on wait a thing what thing thing
isn't a very descriptive noun yeah I
know it's intentionally on descriptive
moving on part 2 the body the middle of
the sternum is called the body anatomist
SAR so bad at naming so during the first
half of the project for awesome all the
money raised will be split between Save
the Children and Partners in Health two
organizations doing amazing jobs of
helping the most vulnerable children and
families around the world and thanks to
matching donations I am pleased to
announce that during the first half of
the p4a your donations will be worth
much more money
a group of nerdfighters has gotten
together with Hank of me to offer
$300,000 in matching donations and
generous donors from both Partners in
Health and Save the Children will also
match your donations meaning that
starting at midnight tonight every
dollar you donate to the project for
awesome is worth $4 so thank you to all
our matching donors part three the
xiphoid process which would be a pretty
good name for a band it's time for my
holiday book roundup this year I want to
recommend twelve books that I think will
make excellent holiday gifts let's start
with my three favorite grown-up fiction
books of the year first underground
railroad by Colson whitehead which just
won the National Book Award it is a
haunting and brilliant novel about
American slavery that imagines the
Underground Railroad as an actual
Underground Railroad second Moonglow by
Michael Schaben shape on one of the
problems with being a proper genius like
Michael Chabon is that after you publish
several nearly perfect novels people
start saying oh yeah it's another nearly
perfect novel he's written a bunch of
those but no this is an amazing book
about war and memory and mental illness
I loved it and lastly what is not yours
is not yours by Helen oyeyemi which is
just a transfixing book of fairy
tale-like short stories I promise you
have never read anything like it before
for sci-fi fans another story collection
recommendation Ted Chang's stories of
your life and others one of the stories
in that book was the basis for the
wonderful movie arrival but they're all
my
mind blowing leagoo adieu my other
favorite sci-fi of the year was Nettie
okura force binti which is about a girl
who has to travel across the galaxy to
attend university it's page journey and
exciting but ultimately really moving
young adult fiction I liked a lot of
young adult books this year but I'm
going to limit myself to three
recommendations first ember in the ashes
are thrilling and politically astute
dystopian series then there's the Raven
cycle by Maggie Steve honor for fantasy
fans it's just amazing and if you're
looking for a good while a love story I
recommend the Sun is also a star for
fans of youtubers there are lots of
great books out there by youtubers but I
want to highlight Hannah Hart's
buffering because I think it's a
beautifully written and extraordinarily
touching memoir okay nonfiction two
standouts for me this year first I
contain multitudes a history of microbes
and humanity's relationship with them
that is a fascinating book even if like
myself you are not thrilled by the
notion that half the cells inside of
your body are not strictly speaking
yours and secondly sapiens a sweeping
history of the last 250 thousand or so
years that explores how humans became
the dominant species on the planet and
also what our lives looked like back
when we were in the author's phrase an
animal of no significance and lastly you
know how you have or I hope you have a
quirky and delightful friend who is just
the most fascinating person you know I
have the perfect gift book for that
person textbook Amy Krauss Rosenthal a
wonderfully eccentric memoir that is
enhanced by texting really so Hank those
are 12 books I recommend this holiday
season you will see me on Friday for the
10th annual project for awesome and
screen here's a couple guides on how to
make a good project for awesome video
and a link to the IndieGoGo will be here
once it's live and of course self-care
bunny hopes you're being nice to
yourself and eating your carrots unless
you're allergic to carrots